le 7-8 sport numéro 4 4e édition de
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire 26
minutes pour 1 point complet l'essentiel
du sport bon soit anthony sur wilfrid
bonsoir à tous et au programme de ce
sept huit sports nous parlerons tout
d'abord football et du 32e de finale de
la coupe de france de football féminin
entre le montigny et le psg pour en
parler ce soir avec nous philippe brunel
vous êtes le président de la section
féminine du foot à à montigny bonsoir à
vous par la suite nous parlerons aussi
badminton avec arnaud reichert président
du club de badminton de
magny-les-hameaux car votre club vient
d'être labellisé pour sa formation
bonsoir anne et surtout attendre
puisqu'il est en ligne avec nous tanguy
de lamotte anthony tanguy de lamotte oui
on parle évidemment vendée globe un
tanguy de lamotte bonsoir à vous alors
vous vous n'êtes pas encore arrivé un
françois gabart le vainqueur le tout
jeune vainqueur de prince des mers est
arrivé hier aux sables d'olonne où vous
êtes vous actuellement au large des
côtes brésiliennes c'est ça donc
quelqu'un à quelques centaines de
kilomètres afin km de la côte du brésil
et je suis acquittant de l'équateur donc
je devrais passer l'équateur mercredi
dans l'après midi pour revenir dans
l'hémisphère nord
et alors vous avez dû suivre j'imagine
sur internet l'arrivée de françois
gabart ça donne encore plus envie de
rire de voir les sables d'olonne non oui
oui forcément tva le bruit chacun fait
l'objectif
en plus il a terminé à 78 jours fait à
rougir quand on est du nouveau record de
l'épreuve je suis vraiment content pour
lui
je suis vraiment content pour lui il a
vraiment bien mener son projet pour avec
ordinaire et mais moi je fous étaient au
départ de paraître à son arrivée qui
voulait dire que je suis encore en cours
il ya donc je suis bien content et je
continue mon parcours à mon rythme la
vie de nos bateaux quels sont les états
continuent à mon tour quelles sont les
conditions actuelles parce que vous êtes
sur votre bateau vous avez le temps de
nous répondre vous êtes plutôt détendu
tout va bien à l'heure actuelle
oui tout mariage avec le vent qui vient
de la droite donc il vient de l'afrique
en fait il tout le vert le brésil et moi
je le remonte vers le nord
donc le vent vient de la droite et il ya
innovant donc céder avant tout à fait
tout à fait enfin tropez mais
suffisamment manière pour que pour que
je profite de la chaleur des poissons
volants et puis là j'ai une petite bande
dessinée après midi dans mon hamac donc
les conditions sont très agréables et
ayant pour fils pour regard vers les
batteries après les conditions
difficiles des mères c'est reposant
comme quoi le le vendée globe de temps
en temps alors je crois aussi quand même
que dans les derniers jours vous avez
fait un peu de plongée et tanguy il ya
quelques jours devant j'avais pas devant
du tout et donc j'en ai profité pour
aller inspecter va prendre ce qui permet
de diriger le bateau qui avait été
endommagé par un bout de bois quelques
jours auparavant et j'ai pu rencontre de
l'étendue des dégâts donc
donc voilà c'est fait pour théophile
pour me rafraîchir et puis et puis du
coup j'en ai profité pour pour faire des
belles images mais on vous voit
justement à l'heure actuelle rend aux
humains et on les voit et on voit les
images à l'heure actuelle où vous êtes
accroché en haut de votre mal et alors
vous êtes 11e au classement général à
l'heure actuelle on veut on peut dire
que votre place et consolidées il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de course
poursuite avec le dixième devant vous
malheureusement les conditions faibles
de la dernière tempête
avec un impôt un peu plus récents il a
fait un peu échappé donc je pense que
vers france pourrait par le rattraper
avant l'étape de l'homme l'état paraît
tout à fait logique la logique de
l'albera tôt et a fait respecter
donc moi je suis très très bien à cette
rafle à ce qui compte pour moi était de
fait de terminer au niveau de nos
bateaux et en ayant fait une belle
trajectoire et donc voilà je continue à
appliquer sur la vigilance est encore
pas mal de kilomètres
profitez de profiter des derniers
moments mais parce qu'ils avaient une
belle opération derrière tout ça va en
tenir
oui il y avait une belle opération aussi
on le rappelle on le rappelle c'est que
vous êtes donc skippers d'initiatives
coeur et donc vous vous naviguiez au
profit de d'enfants qui peuvent être
opérés par la suite suite à des clics
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est ça
s'appelle nick eric l'appliquer des
initiatives ils ont monté un fonds
d'actions pour pouvoir aider
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque est en fait à chaque fois que
quelqu'un va cliquer sur les frites
initiative créée à coeur point fr eh ben
mon compteur s'engage à donner 1 euro de
la part de lavernose à la vocation est
donc ça permet d'opérer les enfants
fatou 12000 euros pour opérer un enfant
combien de temps vous avez sauvé
relancerait plaisir en france et pour
l'instant on n'avait pas fait il ya
quelques jours avoir des formes il
clique donc pas représente déjà plus de
huit enfants qui ont été opérés et
prouver d'olive est arrivé merci tanguy
de lamotte
bravo pour cette belle initiative on
vous souhaite bien évidemment bonne
chance à entonner pour la suite de la
compétition merci à vous d'avoir été en
ligne avec nous et puis bien sûr vous
passerez sur ce plateau une fois arrivé
à l'arrivée c'est 20 février c'est ça
dont deux dans deux semaines à peu près
on peut on peut prévoir votre arrivée le
long des sables d'olonne ouais vers le
haut à la veille de la saint-valentin
bas ce serait parfait effectivement
merci tanguy de lamotte d'avoir été donc
en ligne en communication avec vous
depuis depuis votre bateau justement il
en pleine mer tanguy de lamotte poursuit
il poursuit ce vendée globe alors que
françois gabart lui est arrivé ce
week-end vous l'avez forcément suivi
mais vous téléspectateurs allez vous
continuer à suivre le vendée globe
jusqu'à l'arrivée du dernier
vos réponses non je suis pas suivre j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient faim le record du
monde le petit jeune donc j'étais très
content de lui mais non la vraie ça
m'intéresse pas trop ah oui je vais
attendre les autres arriver parce qu'ils
ont peut-être dans une semaine par an
contre 3 4 jours déjà le troisième
et après on verra quand dimanche
prochain à l'autre personnellement je ne
suis jamais ça mais bon c'est sûr les
infos sur la radio j'ai écouté mais
sinon non je ne m'intéresse pas trop
bien sûr je ne vais pas laisser tomber
les 3e et les autres il serait il reste
12 tu crois vive le vendée globe et
poursuivre tanguy de lamotte restait
bien évidemment sur tv fil 78 on
poursuit avec du football on l'espère
éditions à venir à montigny le pg va
venir à montigny pas installer son
centre d'entraînement mais pour jouer un
match de coupe de france se fera encore
attendre un vrai d'ailleurs pour le
centre à l'entraînement même si on le
sait les dirigeants du psg ont toujours
le dossier de saint quentin en yvelines
sous le coude et n'ont pas encore
tranché pour l'installation du futur
camp des loges
en attendant il ya ce choc veut pg
montigny en coupe de france de football
féminin 32e de finale et pour en parler
sur ce plateau philippe brunel vous êtes
donc le président de la section football
féminin à montigny bonsoir à vous merci
bonsoir
alors avant de parler plus au moment de
comprendre tous les problèmes autour de
ce report qui de ce match qui devait
être une fête et qui se transforment en
véritables véritable calvaire
nous avons essayé de comprendre un peu
les raisons de ces problèmes de dates et
d'horaires concernant ce 32e de finale
avec elodie moines ce match devait être
une fête pour tous les animaux atteints
mais ce 32e de finale de la coupe de
france de football féminin entre
montigny et le psg se transforme en
calvaire
suite aux fortes chutes de neige les
terrains de football yvelinois sont
impraticables et le stade de la couldre
nisha pas programmé à l'origine ce
dimanche 27 janvier à 14h30
la rencontre est d'abord reporté par la
fédération française de football aux
mercredis à 14h30 aussi puis finalement
à 20 heures la déception est alimentaire
et grands au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
une fête parce que mettre un match à
14h30 c'est aberrant pour les filles
parce que les filles travaillent on
n'est pas des pros elles sont prêts à
elle travaille et termine à 18 heures
voire 19 heures le soir on va composer
parce que là où j'ai pas de terrain les
terrains sont fermés on veut un
s'entraîner en salle on va aller faire
des footings et ont essayé de trouver
une solution
j'ai une semaine pour trouver une
solution est trouvée défi apte à jouer
mercredi prochain les tribunes du
terrain d'honneur du stade de la couldre
resteront vides
la rencontre va devoir se jouer sur le
terrain synthétique du club
seule surface jouable du côté unis
montrent un on crie au favoritisme
les dates de report proposé par le club
saint quentinois le 3 et le 10 février
ne convenait pas au paris saint germain
disons que ce sont des jeunes à
l'international et que l'international a
représenté qui peut contrôler antilles
les filles de jean dany grosser ont en
tout cas une motivation de plus pour
renverser l'ogre parisien mercredi soir
lors de ce choc
classée à risques philippe que d'
aventure pour organiser cette rencontre
donc ce match qui devait être une fête
bonjour cauchemar maintenant on en est
revenue on va essayer de faire une belle
petite fête pour le jeu mais
effectivement il aurait eu lieu à 14h30
nous aura permis de mettre en valeur
notre club
mon équipe qui est des joueuses d'anne
honteuse niveau des deux bon niveau et
puis d'affronter comme le psg maintenant
on va dire qatar avec version qatarie la
suédoise à cela ni sur les crozes et ça
ça a permis de fédérer des joueurs
extérieurs d'éventuels sponsors parce
que nous on n'est pas le cadreur donc il
faut qu'on boucle le budget donc voilà
donc c'est bon ben maintenant une fois
la déception passée on est en route pour
organiser ce match mercredi soir au
stade de la gaude sur le terrain
synthétique qui aura un bon niveau 1 sur
la pelouse y aura du beau jeu on dit
souvent on parle forcément du psg est
très souvent notamment pour les pros est
de zlatan mais il n'ya pas que les quais
pas aux mains les bills féminine chez
les qataries ont beaucoup investi
tout à fait et alors suite à cette
décision donc le match est reporté bon
on le sait tous maintenant et vous crier
quand même au favoritisme
vous avez l'impression d'être un peu
laissé laissés pour compte dans cette
affaire le oui et non oui parce que bon
ben c'est le pg mais eux ils ont des
impératifs
parce que nous on avait demandé à jouer
le 10 février qui est à dimanche à 14h30
pourra mettre une organisation passé
vous il faut savoir qu'on a fait des
affiches que les affiches sont caduques
on n'a pas tant le déroff ou n'avait
proposé le 9 à 16 heures effectivement
l'entraîneur du psg a des international
français les jouets d'oise et européenne
allemande puisque je crois que le match
amical c'est français demandent
allemagne pardon donc effectivement
voilà maintenant on met tout en oeuvre
pour c'était ce soir on a une réunion
avec la mairie les forces de l'ordre
pour essayer de parce que bon
effectivement il ya eu à peu près 500
personnes minimum 60 je pense que ça va
fédérer aussi bien les garçons parce que
le pg il ya le lpg hommes mais le pgd
conduit pg voilà j'allais y venir là
vous parlez de cette réunion qu avec les
forces de l'ordre parce que le match est
classé à risques on savoure le match et
décalé et en bis qui songe avec les
conditions climatiques
en plus le match et ariana donc alors
suite à nos contacts avec la fédération
et nous a dit que c'était classé à
risque du fait de d'une vingtaine de
supporters qui sont interdits de stade
suite à la faire de la politique
sécuritaire et qui profitent de toutes
les petites installations un peu pour
venir alors donc je pense que mercredi
matin en conseil
il faut qu'on mette en place avec la
police la mairie
des solutions il faut pas non plus tôt
qu'on tombe dans la psychose parce que
c'est mercredi
bon je pense qu'il fera relativement
frais encore donc sa drogue ça devrait
aller
le principal c'est match de coupe pour
que le pg je sens que les filles sont
assez motivés même surmotivés donc je
pense que c'est justement sur un plan
sportif allez on oublie lui a laissé un
défi là doivent être encore les modifier
oui effectivement parce que bon déjà les
filles veulent jouer ce mercredi qu donc
la priorité c'est au choix des joueuses
puisque c'est des amateurs ils sont pas
le dimanche on part à 7h30 heure on
vient à 20h et dia aucun argent chez
chez les joueuses la moue du président
on veut jouer donc on joue donc voilà
c'est un match de coupe
normalement on le joue dix fois on vous
risquent de le perdre deux fois mais
c'est un match de coupe
et donc voilà je pense que il ya
peut-être un coup à jouer
un petit pronostic justement sur ce coup
le pronostic pour moi c'est 1-0 à la
mi-temps pour bottini égalisation et on
gagne aux tirs au but notre capitaine
qui s'investit alors ça c'est
précisément la vérité
scénario est bien dans la rue et on
gagne aux tirs au but voilà vous avez le
temps de le repasser le film en plus
j'avais déjà joué ça serait bien mais la
logique ça c'est que le psg se qualifie
qu'on fasse un bon match qu'on voit les
qualités de mon équipe et que après
qu'on devienne le supporter numéro 1 du
psg n'allait pas fâché le psg si le psg
doit venir s'installer à lille ne soyez
pas trop et du ravec
on a déconné pas fâché on a des bons
rapports ont d'ailleurs on en profite
pour remercier le pg qui quand même
accepté de jouer à 20 heures parce que
sans leur accord le match était
maintenue à 14h30 et à s'arrêter
un site autre problème pour pour le club
local de montigny pour mobiliser les
joueuses à oui tout à fait merci
beaucoup
philippe des merci à vous de m'avoir à
vidéo de tv fier ce soir sans transition
escrime wilfried ce week-end le club
d'escrimé de tram de trap organisé son
traditionnel challenge interclubs une
compétition réservée aux jeunes tireurs
âgés de 6 à 12 ans l'occasion de repérer
des futurs compétiteurs reportage cinq
mois après le fiasco français aux jeux
olympiques ils sont toujours aussi
nombreux à manier l'épée lors du
challenge de trappes environ 160 enfants
âgés de 6 à 12 ans découvre la
compétition tout en s'amusant sur la
piste j'ai fait trois victoires et une
défaite là on commence le tableau mais
enfin le truc c'est de gagner si on perd
mais c'est pas trop grave mais on va
essayer de gagner quand même cette
rencontre interclubs est aussi
l'occasion pour les maîtres d'armes de
trouver d âme de compétiteur et ça
permet de repérer quelques talents ça
permet de voir un peu aussi pour eux que
ce qu'on fait à l'entraînement va ça
sert en compétition ça leur permet de
gérer leur stress aussi
ce qu'il y en a qui pleurait déjà ce
matin et beaucoup de monde il ya
beaucoup de pistes ya vingt pistes pour
les enfants ça fait beaucoup de monde
parmi ces talents de demain jeunes
tireurs trappistes nourrit de grandes
ambitions
vainqueur de la rencontre régionale de
rueil malmaison il ya quelques jours
simon jalbert reste serein et centré sur
son objectif malgré un premier match de
poule perdu j'ai perdu d'un point dans
je suis un peu déçu d'avoir perdu mon
premier match mais je pense que les
prochains matches je pourrais aller
gagner et je me déconcentre pas je
compte la gagner cette compétition comme
à rueil et j'espère que je veux faire
une bonne compétition
simon sera éliminée en quarts de finale
et termine sixième de la compétition
au classement général le vésinet
remporte le challenge devant trappe
et puis je vous rappelle un seul match
de football entre montigny le bretonneux
les féminines de montigny-le-bretonneux
face au psg 32e de finale de la coupe de
france féminine stade de la couldre à
montigny ce mercredi à 20h30 tout et
leurs alliés mais complet sur téléphiles
jeudi tout à fait nous allons passer
maintenant au badminton puisque le club
de magny les hameaux était reçu en tant
qu' en tant que club forme former les
formateurs surtout pour le pour le label
deux étoiles puisqu'il ya cinq étoiles
décernées par la fédération française de
badminton et donc que vous êtes avec
nous pour en parler ce soir arnaud
reichert le président du club devant
soir à vous bonsoir anthony alors ça
intrigue un petit peu ce label deux
étoiles quand on quand on s'est
rencontrés la première fois je vous ai
dit en quoi ça consiste
le label en quoi ça consiste cinq
étoiles effectivement la fédération
française de badminton a mis en place
tout un dispositif pour les écoles de
badminton en france l'idée c'est de
pouvoir effectivement se marque était
auprès des joueurs et auprès des
communes par deux étoiles c'est déjà un
accueil pour les enfants voire un
certain nombre de licenciés enfants
également d'avoir un certain nombre de
séances encadrées pour ses enfants
donc là c'est les 2 étoiles il ya des
critères bien spécifiques ainsi tout
aussi par exemple que vous ayez un
professeur diplômé d'état qui soit au
sein de au sein de votre club exactement
donc on va pas sauter les étapes
on est en école de badminton depuis
seulement deux ans donc on a passé la
première la seconde
l'objectif c'est d'aller à la troisième
étoile effectivement être entraîneur
diplômé donc on fera tout pour remplir
les critères
dès l'année prochaine pour voir ses
trois étoiles alors comment les obtient
ses étoiles il faut faire un dossier où
c'est la fédération qui vont contacter
directement
non tous les ans nous avons un dossier à
remplir avec un certain nombre de
critères qui ont une pondération ex un
certain nombre de points et le nombre de
points
donnez les étoiles auquel vous plus vous
pouvez prétendre
c'est en quelque sorte pour parler
concrètement une obligation de résultat
un petit peu une récompense du travail
du club
alors il ya une obligation de résultat
je ne sais pas mais c'est une récompense
a effectivement pour l'encadrement sur
tous les bénévoles qui qui travaillent
au sein du club des différents clubs de
badminton et qui emploie puisque vous
faites on a un employé qui est
l'entraîneur et c'est une vraie
reconnaissance et c'est un gage de
qualité pour les enfants
et alors quand on a deux étoiles on a
envie d'aller chercher la troisième puis
la quatrième est ce que vous avez les
structures justement pour aller les
chercher ses étoiles à 2 alors là mais
je pense qu'on a là on a la structure
pour aller chercher la troisième étoile
ensuite la 4e à la 5e sont c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué parce qu'il
faut plus de plus en cadrant dans le
bureau du club
il faut plus de terrain parce qu'il faut
qu'on ait beaucoup plus d'adhérents donc
ensuite c'est une discussion avec la
mairie c'est est ce que les bénévoles
veulent s'investir beaucoup plus avec
les enfants ou paraisse que les parents
sont prêts à s'investir
parce qu'effectivement dès qu'on va
avoir 4 5 étoiles il faut faire des
tournois raccompagner les enfants il
faut des gens disponibles et en plus
vous au sein de votre club il ya
quasiment que des bénévoles
mise à part exacte au lisseur diplômés
c'est exactement on n'est que des
bénévoles on dort on a comme salarié ses
professeurs et alors donc votre
formation est désormais de plus en plus
reconnues en terme en termes de qualité
mais aussi il y à quelques spécificités
du côté du badminton à magny les hameaux
je crois effectivement un van lint amani
badminton on essaye d'avoir un club qui
est plutôt loisirs et famille donc on
accueille tous les joueurs qu'ils soient
confirmés ou débutants et c'est ce qui
fait un petit peu le charme de notre
club c'est qu'on arrive à accueillir des
gens qui ont la quarantaine ou la
cinquantaine quand j'allais jouer avec
des jeunes qui ceux qui se battent déjà
en départementale ou ou même en
régionale et donc c'est amusant de
pouvoir mixer un petit peu tous ces
profils et dur ensemble et c'est pas
frustrant pour les jeunes commencent à
avoir un bon niveau justement là moi
j'estime c'est un partage le club cirque
on a des séances qui sont faites pour
vraiment faire
ils vont travailler la compet et des
séances qui sont là pour partager avec
les autres et former quelque part les
enfin les débutants et les compétiteurs
sont là pour leur montrer les bons
gestes en dehors et à côté de cet espace
un peu compétition il ya aussi des
entraînements dédié spécifiquement à des
jeunes qui sont en difficulté c'est un
sujet qui nous est chère depuis cette
année effectivement on a une maman qui
est venu s'inscrire cette année dans le
club qui a un enfant qui est
dyspraxiques elle est arrivée que ce mot
là je ne sais pas du tout ce que c'était
je me suis renseigné donc c'est un
enfant qui a du mal à coordonner tous
les gestes alors aussi bien les
commandes du cerveau droit cerveau
gauche avec les bras les jambes il a
fait tout un tas d'autres sports donc je
lui dis coûte bien faire une séance
d'essai la première séance a été un peu
compliqué l'enfant essayer de retourner
dans les jupons de sa maman finalement
il s'est inscrit
et depuis plusieurs semaines on le voit
progresser et c'est un garçon qui prend
énormément de plaisir et je trouve que
pour ce type de maladie c'est vraiment
un sport qui est fabuleux parce qu'on
est là en coordination et un peu de
stratégie un peu de tactique la
coordination et l enfant est vraiment un
cas de oui merci beaucoup arnaud d'être
venu ce soir sur le plateau de tv filet
puis on suivra n'ont peut-être la
troisième étoile l'année prochaine merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci de votre
accueil impasse du badminton à présent
au kick boxing
oui il y avait un stage de self défense
et de kickboxing vous y avaient
participé wilfrid maison ça fait bien
sûr comme avec comme tous les dimanches
oui qui était organisée donc à bois
d'arcy et contrairement aux apparences
ces deux disciplines kick boxing et
celle des chansons sont plutôt
complémentaires des initiations toujours
très utile pour pour répondre aux
situations difficiles reportage
je m'en vais
le temps qu'ils se relèvent j'ai déjà
gagné du temps comment réagir lors d'une
agression le self défense apporte
quelques réponses pour avoir les bons
réflexes dans ce type de situation
toujours difficile
l'effet de surprise est telle qu'on n'a
aucun réflexe et donc c'est ça qui est
bien c'est que là on apprend avoir des
réflexes en cas de besoin est ce que
vous avez appris jusque là alors des
petits coups faciles à faire ou on n'a
pas besoin de beaucoup de forces pour
père malade et se donner le temps de
partir à fond la caisse et d un maximum
de personnes à pouvoir avoir le réflexe
de mettre un doigt dans l'oeil de m un
coup dans la gorge de mettre un coup
dans les parties génitales de pain c'est
de crier de s'en sortir avec les
éléments qu'on a sur soi ce moment là
les participants de ce stage organisé à
bois d'arcy apprennent à se défendre sur
les saisies par de simples pressions sur
les endroits sensibles du corps humain
et la réaction est automatique faut le
maîtriser en fait on le maîtrise pas
encore donc à force de s'exercer on va
de maîtriser par la suite je pense que
c'est efficace
au programme également la découverte du
kickboxing la boxe pieds poings une
discipline complémentaire du paint
jacques sylla avec le kickboxing sport
de percussion c'est
on va apprendre à donner des coups des
coups de poing des coups de pied on va
enchaîner les coups pieds et poings et
la self défense va venir en
complémentarité où on va essayer de
neutraliser
la personne en cas d'agression pour soi
opté pour la fuite soit il à mettre par
terre
et si vous avez un problème de garde
demandé aux jeunes prochain stage le 16
février à voisins le bretonneux
l'essentiel du sport sur tv films 7,8
sport en passant résultats du week-end
avec la suite des intempéries neige
qu'il ya eu il ya quelques semaines il
n'y a évidemment pas eu encore de
rencontres ce week-end c'est toujours la
trêve hivernale obligatoire pour les
clubs de football et de rugby
tous les matchs ont été reportés à la
fin de la saison évidemment donc statuto
statu quo au classement que ce soit dans
les championnats de rugby ou football
logiquement les championnats reprennent
ce week end en revanche il y avait du
hand et également du basket ce week end
seconde victoire consécutive pour les
féminines de montigny-le-bretonneux
handball
les coéquipières de gabriel parloir se
sont imposés sur le parquet de
hazebrouck de justesse 28 27 clubs
d'ailleurs aussi qui lutte pour le
maintien en nationale 2 les joueuses de
stéphane paysans remonte du coup à la 6e
place et peuvent désormais croire à leur
avenir en nationale 2 côté basket
championnat de france de nationale 2
masculins 13e défaite de la saison pour
l'étoile sportive des cheminots de
trappes qui s'incline 78 à 73
les joueurs trappistes semble avoir
renoncé un peu à tout espoir de maintien
chez les femmes petit événement ce week
end wilfried car l'entente le chesnay
versailles a connu sa seconde vague à la
saison à vouloir la possible 59 à 56
elles n'ont pas été assez agressive en
défense en seconde mi-temps les je
devine code barres dietsch reste
toutefois leader de leur championnat
avec deux points d'avancé sur calais on
poursuit avec ses résultats du
volley-ball 13e et avant dernière
journée du championnat de régionale une
ce week-end l'ice montini volley-ball
recevait paris camou malgré une bonne
entame de match les inimités rate trop
d'occasions notamment aux smashes et ont
manqué de régularité sur l'ensemble de
la rencontre
ils perdent les deux premiers sets 25-23
avant d'arracher la troisième manche 25
20 mais paris plus beaucoup plus
constant conclut la quatrième manche sur
le même score et l'emportent 3 7 1 quant
à plaisir villepreux le leader de
régionales une il s'est repris avec la
réception de fresnes les plaisirs oise
se sont imposés 3 sets à 1 au classement
quand on voit tout de suite plusieurs
villes premier toujours leader lésigny
matin sont quant à eux 6e avec un match
en moins cependant mais ils devront se
battre jusqu'au bout pour leur maintien
voilà pour ses résultats concernant le
volley pour les amateurs de cyclisme à
présent il ya le paris-nice bientôt ça
passera par le département des yvelines
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler pigalle
tour de france au 6e tour de france le
tracé a été dévoilé il ya quelques
semaines et ça va passer par saint
quentin en yvelines
la dernière étape de cette 100e édition
longue de 118 km partira de versailles
du château précisément pour rejoindre
les champs elysées le peloton effectuera
quelques tours de roue à guyancourt
montigny-le-bretonneux
voisins-le-bretonneux et
magny-les-hameaux avant de prendre la
direction de la vallée de chevreuse et
puis on termine par du football le
mercato se déroule toujours en ce moment
et puis il ya 11 joueurs dans des clubs
formateurs de saint quentin en yvelines
qui est concerné oui encore trois jours
de mercato avant la clôture et donc le
joueur concerné c'est évidemment
massadio haïdara nous l'avons rencontrée
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année il
revenait sur ses terres à la verrière
issus de la verrière
l'international espoirs et arrière
gauche de nancy lorraine a signé un
contrat de cinq ans et demi avec le club
anglais de newcastle
il rejoint la colonie française des deux
de hatem ben arfa yohan cabaye et les
gens passent mal chez eux debuchy chez
les magpies
merci entonné en ré vous la semaine
prochaine même heure prochain 7,8 sport
oui n'hésitez pas à commenter le 7-8
sport sur twitter ils nous donnaient
tous les résultats de vos clubs à lundi
prochain bonne soirée